[Music]
dorsal round
official crisis of
maternal sprites research is delfín from between
the million wendy guayas scratching the
surface I went to the casting of type from rhode
island walking greed
we came from cairo neinver see if he
really wants and in amazonas refuge without
tambo for darwin  forest
we fight to discover is not explicit
different group soffin sex objective of
bayer schering of the incredible amos
son rainford
wing are you going to see gates garden refuge
people with wifi col lectius pittsford
and saints
[Music]
type scientific thinkers background
angel and on stage
for asthma injuries lakers observation the
collection of analysis excel
[Music]
whitfield work
the white star of inception like
collected experiment from we stand a
container soccer of samples your natural
history museum in lima
kors with the help of one degrees
specialist of america
My name is Juan Grados Arauco. I am an
entomologist.
I dedicate myself to studying trade unions
where they live.  and evolution of these
organisms
in 2016 we have had seven new
species for proven sciences
these species mean that the
human being does not know them you do not find them
in encyclopedias you do not find them in
museums you do not find them anywhere they
are new when one publishes it is  a
new species is just going to make known
to the whole world how this really is I
received this specimen a few days ago
that they sent me from the jungle and I have
studied it carefully this specimen is
a new species for science
good
black birds on the wings  dar wang
guosheng space is your man real
problem green guest orchard to
collect is pisces wonder was a
feeling
really it would be very difficult to have this
type of work without the help of
visitors he
does not love what he does not know if we
know more in depth the species
that live on the planet obviously that
we are going to want to conserve much more
[Music]